[Laughter]
hey everybody I'm Ashley from BuzzFeed
and today I'm here with realtor.com I'm
going to try and help Eric and his very
cute dog rank or fine be perfect home
today I am going to get a house my best
friend in the whole world
rancor I'm here to help my best friend
Eric find a new place for him and his
dog rancor it'd be great to have that
amazing personal space that's mine and
so finally like relaxing that's what I'm
looking for that's my need I'd love to
hear your guys's story when I was in
university I'm where there's a burger
stand like a block away from my house so
I walked this burger Sam then she comes
up to me I'm like oh hello stray dog
here's a fry and she eats it and then I
walk back home and she follows me all
the way home so she kind of found me and
I'm super glad she did I love being
close to the city but also having a
little bit of that like suburb II vibe
it looks like there's a bit heartbreak
there yeah this park actually won that
rancor and I have gone to a few times
she loves this part and there's like
properties close to it which is a little
Oh so this is the house I was born and
raised in living with your folks it's
not just my stuff it's all of their
stuff too some spots why do you hide
pending continue because that means
someone might be in contracted oh that's
awesome oh this is cool built in 1907 so
the reason that I'm here today is
because I specialize in DIY decorating I
do a lot of those videos for BuzzFeed
I'm also really excited because I get to
hang out with one of the cutest dogs in
the world and it's gonna be a fun day
for the rest of my life I could drink a
morning cup of coffee that's it right
there with rancor and just like people
watch every morning so I'm hoping we can
help Eric and rank [ __ ] turn one of
these houses into their home and the
star of today's tour oh I love it so far
the outside is incredible
all right should we check it out I'm
very ready
oh those spots you put the basketball
court outside but like there's a section
right here we just we'd have a two
living room scenario rancor how do you
like this other living room right now
okay the kitchen's right in the center
and I feel like a lot of the
entertainment that I like to host and do
when my friends are over here is you
know in the kitchen it's over here this
is a nice bedroom and it's the only one
on the first floor also there's a
bathroom if this was the guest room
that'd be a perfect setup I don't know
if this needs to be a rancor cave or
something I think rancor gets a room
Eric that's the crawl space great I can
put my one pair of jeans here and my two
sweaters over here and you get me out
here you can have coffee in the morning
I think a big thing for me especially
living in LA is the amount of noise can
really mess with rancor but oh no this
is one of those parts of town where it's
show oh your favorite high rank or how
do you like the backyard great she's
exploring I think it's might be your
second favorite area it's one of the
things you like about this place I love
the amount of space I love the guest
rooms oh we have another house to see no
this is very overwhelming but I'm having
a great time
I like it already it reminds me of the
house that I used to live in when I went
to college this is the older house she's
very frightening
you can plant specific vegetables I'm
impressed with the outside should we go
inside I would love the inside
let's see some ghosts this is a lard or
do we have windows in this fish in the
size of a full size mattress so one
issue they're kind of forcing already is
there aren't really locks on these doors
this is a bathroom a important lockable
Randall operator oh it almost feels like
a set you know like a cooking show set
you pour the whole milk in the series
nice backyard
oh hello but no grass rancor how do you
feel about the mulch actually before we
go upstairs we should look at the
basement can we do a show down there
we'll see we can fit a solid three to
four audience members I love this
there's so many unconventional ways to
use closet space it could be an inset
office so this is a fun space to get
creative with yeah this is the spot it's
pretty gorgeous
so both houses are amazing what are your
pros with the first house it was super
modern which I liked a lot of a sucker
to have a guest room downstairs if I
have our friends visit they can see them
there I can stay in my domain upstairs
yeah the backyard rancour was running
around she was having a great time the
cons of the first house was definitely
the size it was a little smaller but
what about this ghost house
I liked the basement it was funky it
feels like a classy house does that old
feel what at the concept goes yes I
don't know how I'd feel living here by
myself biggest con of this house is not
just one thing but all the little things
from realizing that might have to do
landscaping to more space just having
more furnished space that ought to buy
things for and those are little money
things that just add on to the bigger
price tag of the actual
house so how many under bites does each
house actually yeah a solid 500 bites
out of five under bites to this house
the first house though it gets a solid
six under bites out of five on their
body one with house number one yeah oh
my gosh before we get the actual house
we do need to go back to realtor calm
get you guys a realtor and get this
process started let's do it
rancor how pump to you to move into that
first house she's excited let's move
into a new house rancor Johnny went
house hunting yeah